which within the scientific community in
order to foster and promote a broader
appreciation for the process of science
I think most of the time people are
exposed to the product of science and
they don't necessarily appreciate the
failure in the iterations that are
taking place as part of the process and
if you want to help people connect with
science in more ways so that they can
appreciate that science is in fact part
of your everyday life and everything
that you do and so we've been working to
achieve this goal for many years and you
might have seen throughout the number of
students and teachers that walk through
our door every single day sitting here
eating pizza or in the lab and we've
been serving primarily the k-12
community through our outreach and we're
also helping to support scientists
through mentor training science
communication training science outreach
training and general support throughout
but our capacity for the in-house stuff
has become incredibly saturated like for
example we have the lab Experience
Program and this is a program where a
teacher can find their entire class and
come for a field trip
this happens three to five times a week
throughout the school year we would open
up the slots to sign up for this program
and for the entire year we sell out in
12 minutes like we are just there's so
much demand for the programming and we
just don't have a supply so we were
thinking about how can we do better how
can we serve the broader communities
better give science and the process of
science and opportunities to engage in
science and authentic ways how can we do
that to more audiences who don't
necessarily have a Rockefeller
University situated in their city and so
we worked and also our programs are a
hundred percent agreed to everybody so
that's a really
important things to us and so we wanted
to build something that would also
maintain that type of equity and access
and so and additionally over the years
we've accumulated a huge amount of
scientific materials through our
wonderful scientists who create
curricula for science Saturday a few of
you are here today and your faces are up
here on the website somewhere which
we'll go through and also we've been
working with teachers throughout the New
York City school system to co-create
things that makes sense for that type of
setting and it's not just us going in
and saying like I am scientists hear me
roar but it's what do you need from
science what are your limitations with
science and how can we fill in those
caps how can we support you better in
what you're doing to serve the
educational communities and so we went
so given the demand for more outreach
and also given the fact that we just
have this amazing resource and amazing
scientists who are contributing and
amazing teachers who've been
contributing around the years we went to
the Lowenstein foundation and we were we
were granted with the help of our
awesome development team we were given
up this lovely grant to start this this
Web site and so before I take you
through a tour I would love to introduce
my Copts Minh who has been one of the
major influences on how we're thinking
about building this and has been an
incredible partner with the CNG partners
to help us create something that was
functional and also incredibly beautiful
so I'd like to introduce Maya and then
I'll I'll give some remarks about the
process
[Applause]
he was an experienced portion of the
website and a lot of the functionality a
lot of the thinking behind how to
organize the content its attributed to
her and we want to make sure that you
probably see my face here a lot I see
your faces a logic is that me or a lot
we worked a lot with Rockefeller
University but it all started jeanny and
when a few years ago she needed a logo
for some science outreach it was not
called
rocky to you at that time and it was a
tiny little project that started this
amazing relationship and a lot of the
stuff the new campus said it's going to
be our word the website for rock to rock
other universities our work read books
and you know recordings perspectives is
all our work and an old store that would
use I wanted to thank you for that and
for this website
we were really attracted to the fact
that it is as you said a free resource
for everybody
and one of the work that we do in saying
to your partners is for social good with
basically doing mostly nonprofit work
and education and what was interesting
to us here is that while it was targeted
towards younger audiences it also had to
work and appeal to educators and to
science enthusiasts and we're very
interested in those projects where we
have to bridge is it's not just like
kind of scholastic you know books where
everything is cued and there are a lot
of creatures it's like it has to be
serious and it has to be fun at the same
time and how do you do that with very
simple tools without making a lot of
creatures that talk to you and try to
make you so we capitalize on science
basically the shapes that are found in
size the molecular structures the colors
that as you can see from the beautiful
mixes that would make here the colors
that are not necessarily
that one to nature but are produced in
the lab and we wanted to create those
electric colors and the whole
progression from one color to another we
also when kind of deep into the geek
factor to look for icons and things that
would relate to people even if they're
not that obvious and I remember the
reactions when we Chris presented that
arrow and said this is our notation yeah
yeah we did that one mark even though we
didn't have a degree from Rockefeller
University and we had a lot of fun
geeking out on this project basically
and what also makes it different for us
that we actually read the content of
what we're working on so we learned a
lot especially about kombucha so about
the information architecture which Kim
did a very good job the whole idea was
is how do you structure something that
it would rather eat you know if we're in
the book you had a table of contents but
basically you come to a site like that
and you're looking for something
specific but you're not quite sure what
you're looking for and the way we
structured it is by having a lot of
filters and helping the user find
whether the green level or the type of
experiment or the type of materials they
need they could search in many many ways
and finding what they need and while
they do that they discover new things
and the other thing that was important
to us is create a hierarchy in which you
could sneak into something before you
come into the long page with a lot of
text and a lot of images that was very
important for us to create that
experience where you can simple things
before you commit to them and also make
it very visual and beautiful and fun and
exciting thank you so much but there's a
lot of people that we do need to thank
before I take everybody's for a tour
first and foremost I am so fund that
DeSantis and did this whole thing almost
entirely from our end of it almost
entirely
she's been really working on this for
years and pouring her heart and soul I
don't even think she took my maternity
leave because she was working on this
which I like Oh like I keep saying that
but she is actually sicked her skids
were sick today and she was sick today
and this is like the first time she's
ever missed work for being sick and of
course it's on her day so I can't think
to Stan enough for the amazing work and
passion that she poured into this into
this project and I wish you were here I
also want to thank again CNG so Maya cam
Leslie in all of your team the wonderful
team at data aren't they there are a
what is it like a coding firm yeah they
like little the code for it they're in
Moscow it was pretty cool
the wonderful team in IT so Louise Jason
and George Anthony and the needs thank
you so much for supporting this project
and helping us bring it into into
fruition CPA thank you Meghan Lori and
Katie for all the support that you gave
this of course to Lowenstein and our
development team to help us secure the
funding for it our co-creators so we
have been working really closely with
the teachers New York City public school
teachers who were a part of that for
America
they've been pull creating a lot of this
with us and so we've had the pleasure of
just learning from them and learning
their experiences so that we can shape
something that makes sense for everybody
to use all of our science Saturday's
scientists of course and we've been
working in the National Space with a lot
of people from the science outreach
community across the United States and
everybody it's been just wonderful and
sharing their thoughts and ideas around
science outreach which helped to shape
how we think about science outreach so I
just wanted to give this eye out folks a
nice big shout out and now I'd love to
take you through a little bit this was
supposed to be dis and speech but I'll
do my best to represent this
so as you can see we have a couple of
different arms up here we have teaching
resources so these are things that allow
teachers to engage in science and some
really interesting and creative and
innovative ways we have cornerstore
experiments these are this is coming
soon but basically we're making this
with New York City teachers that will
include number one research frameworks
so how to iterate how to think about
failure how to design an experiment as
well as model systems so science can be
really expensive how can we have
protocols and create systems that are
robust and flexible but also accessible
and can be purchased from like Home
Depot or a bodega we originally wanted
to call it what data science but then we
learned OData means a lot of things
outside of New York City so corner store
it is and as you can see we have these
like cute little animations which I just
like and Gotha over we also I think this
might actually be the first guide to
science outreach for scientists ever and
so we've been working really hard to
take all of the years of outreach that
we owe the lesson learned from the years
of outreach that we've been doing so we
can share with the community we think
outreach is a really important component
of the scientific enterprise and the
more we can do to support other
scientists as they engage in outreach
them I think the better off science will
be and then of course we have our blog
so I want to take you quickly through
the teaching resources so here we have
we hope to have a ton of different
scientific disciplines represented but
what I think is very unique about the
way in which we are promoting though use
of these resources is not necessarily
like in terms of like Kaiser twelve or
fourth grade or third grade or something
like that but instead we've decided to
do them in these four buckets no-show
explore and relate so with the note this
will be essentially like the
fundamentals the backgrounds maybe it's
a little biochemistry a little history
things into context the show will be
demonstrations
how to demonstrate these concepts so
that it's a little bit more tangible how
to explores our section on how to dive
deeper how to ask your own questions
maybe explore some labs through inquiry
and then it will aid and this is the
part I think that's missing from a lot
of scientific instruction is how does
this stuff why does it matter what cut
is it relate and how can I act on it and
I think by framing it in these four
buckets we can create a more cohesive
and holistic picture of what science
actually means and so I definitely
encourage you to explore some of these
things and the computers around and
another thing I guess I'll just show you
quickly is our night to science outreach
so we are defining outreach essentially
as a framework and while Rob PDU
participates in science outreach through
informal science education that doesn't
mean it's the only kind of outreach that
you can do so we consider things like
science policy to be outrageous things
like we seems and other types of general
science engage of to be outraged and if
you want to just build continue building
with those frameworks in mind and so
lastly we think it's really important
for representation to be more widespread
when it comes to science and think a lot
of people are really discouraged about
participating in science because they
don't think it's for them or they don't
see anybody that looks like them who who
participate in science and so we've
created we totally bit off a pony and
it's not copyrighted um
which is the humans of New York site and
we've created a scientists of New York
site so if anybody is interested in
participating in the scientists of New
York we'd love to feature you on here
and essentially so this is hobby I don't
know if he's gone but he was here a
second ago and this is his cool planner
shot includes like some cool quotes and
basically trying to cognise scientist
and show that people from all over and
any trajectory
come participate and engage in science
and that we think that's a really
important aspect for for our students
and our audiences to experience and
lastly I also just want to quickly point
out and I have to go through the long
wig so I'm still figuring out how to
navigate we are making sure that anybody
who participates in this work kind of
like we're hoping to eventually bring
this as sort of like a sia archive where
we are essentially curating really high
quality science outreach materials for
the communities to experience and in
doing so we want to make sure that
everybody who contributes to this has
has they're sort of the attribution is
clear so let me bring Karen on because
Karen you're standing right here
oh so Carrie you're not I'm sorry you're
around here somewhere
but Karen created escape the cell and
we're putting her up now and you want to
make sure everybody has attribution so
we hope that this could be a thing that
can Patsy's help with professional
development so it's not just certain
meeting outside community we also think
that it could be a Community Builder for
the in word community and so please
explore take a card if you want to meet
like figure out what our URLs are and
any feedback we'd love to have it and
anybody who would like to contribute
we'd love to talk to you about it so
thank you for coming continue having
some pH indicator gin and tonics and a
great have a great Friday thank you
[Applause]